hey, nora, what's your ethnicity or culture?
I am middle eastern, but it's
one.
bree, what's ethnicity?
hey, mom, what's ethnicity?
I'm from Bangladesh. so
hi, you would say, can we also bianca
western city of culture?
hey, jlo, what's your in the city or culture?
hey, brian, what's your in the city or culture?
hey, guys, what's your city or culture?
hey, what's your ethnicity or culture?
I am half indian and half pakistani.
hey, kim, what's your ethnicity or culture?
uh, I'm filipino.
hey, what's your culture or ethnicity?
I am Colombia and I was born there.
sundus. what is your ethnicity or culture?
I'm a palestinian arab? marhaba.
priscilla, what is your ethnicity or culture?
my ethnicity is, I'm puerto rican.
hey, what's your ethnicity or culture?
so I'm dianelli.
my ethnicity or culture is I'm dominican.
so you're like,
okay with what is your ethnicity or culture? I'm haitian.